quand elle a disparu il y a quelques
mois on a bien senti que l'émotion était
profonde et sincère points deux sanglots
convenu alors à la radio on n'a rien
entendu ses chansons et sa voix mais
aussi sa parole quand elle répondait
fausses interviews
vous nous manquez disaient les
journalistes nos porte parole et elle de
répondre à lons dont j'ai eu mon temps
ma faveur on oubliera et ce sera très
bien comme cela
elle avait tort à quoi tient qu'un
artiste entre dans notre mémoire pour
non plus jamais sortir à son talent à sa
présence à sa sincérité à tout cela à la
fois
probablement il faut se garder des
pronostics qui n'ont au reste aucun
intérêt mais pourquoi faudrait-il
qu'elle s'éloigne de nous n'avons nous
point conserver intact l'image et le son
de damian de piaf
le temps ne fait rien à faire dans le
bel album illustré qu'elle lui consacre
chez calmann-lévy son amie marie chaix
rappelle son exigence qui est tout
simplement celle des plus grands un jour
en tournée elle prétend faire changer un
piano deux scènes qu'elle juge infecte
on lui réplique personne ne s'en
apercevra alors elle pleure de rage
on ne trompe pas le public
ça vous vous